this video was made possible thanks to
our friends over at class
- central.com / Pakman click the link
under this video to browse tens of
thousands of college lectures from the
world's top universities let's talk
about telekinesis also known as psycho
Kinesis it's the ability to influence
physical matter supernaturally with the
mind someone who claims to have
telekinesis claims that they can move or
physically manipulate objects without
physically interacting with that object
so examples can include making an object
levitate transmuting an object into
another object supernaturally affecting
someone's biology such as healing
someone with a disease for example
telekinesis can be thought of as a type
of psychic power but a distinction is
sometimes made between a psychic and a
telekinetic psychics are considered to
be people who know things through
supernatural means telekinetics are
people who can physically move or change
things a person who is knowingly
creating the illusion of manipulating
objects but doesn't claim to have
supernatural powers would call
themselves a magician for example or an
illusionist in this case it's more of a
performance-art but someone who truly
believes that they're able to move
objects with their mind or is trying to
deceive their audience into believing as
much will assert that they're really
telekinetic in the famous Hindu myth
called ma bharata written around 400 BC
one of the two major Sanskrit epics of
ancient India the stories plot centers
around the character Shakuni and his
manipulation of dice to influence a game
in his favor this might be the first
instance of telekinesis known in fiction
then of course there's Jesus who might
be the most famous telekinetic of all
time turning water into wine curing
people of blindness feeding 5,000 people
with five loaves of bread and two fish
according to the New Testament of course
there was the wizard Merlin from The
Legend of King Arthur in the 12th
century who through telekinetic powers
across the ocean in a glass house and
built Stonehenge according to the tale
even though telekinesis has been a theme
in fiction and mythology for centuries
it didn't really gained much popularity
as something actually done in front of
an audience until the 19th century the
term telekinesis was first coined by
Russian writer Alexander axe akov during
his fascination with a British woman
known as Madame desperat Suh performed
seances through Europe tricking people
into believing that she could do things
like talking to the dead using her mind
to move tables making flowers appear out
of thin air acts akov was a journalist
and researcher of supernatural phenomena
and after spending time with DES piron's
praised her wrote about her as a real
honest telekinetic despero's was later
proven to be a fraud beginning in 1880
during a performance where an audience
member actually caught her pretending to
be a ghost few years later during a
performance where she claimed to
dematerialize the lower half of her body
an audience member again caught her
squeezing her legs through the back of
her chair Despero is the first person
described with the word telekinetic is
probably the most famous fraudulent
telekinetic of late 1800s another study
subject of Alexander axe akov was an
Italian woman named you say Pia
Palladino Palladino put on shows murk
making her audience believes she was
able to talk to the dead and levitate
objects the British Society for
psychical research caught Paladino on
multiple occasions just using simple
tricks to create the illusion she
claimed were telekinetic phenomena she
used sleight of hand techniques she used
her foot to move furniture she claimed
to be moving with her mind she even tied
long strands of hair on objects to make
them appear to float in the air world
renowned illusionist Harry Houdini wrote
a book in 1920 called miracle mongers
and their methods and he exposed frauds
like desperat Zinn Palladino the book
actually chronicled the history of fake
telekinetics and gives detailed
explanations of how they created these
illusions there's been widespread
scientific consensus since
the 1800s that telekinesis is pure
pseudoscience in 1988 the National
Research Council in the u.s. actually
commissioned a panel to research this
they reviewed a hundred and thirty years
of past scientific research on
telekinesis and they said in their
conclusion quote evaluation of a large
body of the best available evidence
simply does not support the contention
that these phenomena exists around the
same time the US Army and the National
Academy of Sciences formed a panel to
study the evidence for telekinesis and
to assess whether it might have military
and intelligence applications for
example they wanted to figure out could
individuals use telekinesis to remotely
sabotage enemy weaponry you can be sure
that if there was any validity to
telekinesis the US military would do
everything possible to discover and make
use of it but they had no such luck the
panel was completely unable to find any
scientific evidence to support the
existence of telekinesis so ask yourself
what's more likely that people have been
convinced of telekinesis only through
trickery and faulty experimental design
or that the fields of neuroscience and
physics need to be completely reinvented
to account for telekinesis through
physics we know how matter behaves and
why Caltech physicist Sean Carroll has
written about telekinesis and has
pointed out that all of the objects
telekinetics claimed to bend or levitate
consist of atoms and that any movement
of these atoms would require telekinesis
to use means other than the four known
fundamental forces of nature those were
the strong nuclear force the weak
nuclear force electromagnetism and
gravitation Carroll said that if
telekinesis uses a new undiscovered
fifth fourth of nature simple math shows
that it would need to be about 1 billion
the strength of gravity has to go
undetected by all other prior physics
research and gravity is simply not
strong enough to bend a spoon Carroll
says quote and that's it we are done the
deep lesson is that although science
doesn't know everything
it's not anything goes either there are
well defined regimes of physical
phenomena where we do know how things
work . the place to look for new and
surprising phenomena is outside those
regimes you don't need to set up
elaborate double-blind protocols to pass
judgment on the abilities of purported
psychics British physicist John Taylor
was originally a believer in telekinesis
he was inspired by the supposed
telekinetic uri geller
who's famous for bending metal spoons
and taylor spent four years conducting
research on possible causes of
telekinesis by the end of his long
in-depth exploration Taylor concluded
there's no plausible physical mechanism
for telekinesis Taylor said that all of
the supposed telekinesis he studied
ended up having other naturalistic
explanations and that no actual
telekinesis occurred under
scientifically controlled conditions uri
geller who I mentioned is probably the
most famous purported telekinetic of all
time he's been making TV appearances and
performing for live audiences since the
late 1960s and his career has turned him
into a multimillionaire he's claimed to
have telepathic and telekinetic powers
given to him by aliens his most well
known routine is to bend metal spoons
which he says he does with his mind but
Geller spoon bending has been
demonstrated time and time again by
magicians to be completely possible
through simple magic tricks and illusion
in the early 70s Geller was successfully
sued for fraud and was court ordered to
refund the ticket price to the man who
sued him Geller only agrees to bend
spoons in certain situations he was
enabled to bend any spoons when he
appeared on The Tonight Show with Johnny
Carson in 1973 Nobel prize-winning
physicist Richard Fineman has said that
Geller was unable to perform the trick
on demand when they met in person and as
of 2007 Geller has more or less admitted
that he doesn't actually have
supernatural powers science has long
been eager to find real evidence of
telekinesis
but telekinesis has always managed to
come up short from 1964 to 2015 there
was even a legitimate million dollar
prize offered by the
James Randi Educational Foundation which
we've spoken about before to anyone who
could demonstrate telekinetic or other
supernatural abilities and no one was
ever successful in collecting that
million dollars and still to this day no
scientists have been able to properly
replicate claims about telekinesis in
controlled lab conditions of course it's
true that scientific research has the
ability to completely overturn what we
think we know scientifically it is
possible that someday we'll be able to
prove the existence of telekinesis but
tests must be conducted under the most
stringent conditions to reverse a
century of established science people
claiming telekinetic powers and people
who believe in telekinesis need to
understand why strict standards must be
applied to experiments that examine the
supposed phenomenon it's because
telekinesis would defy facts that are
firmly settled in physics and
neurobiology that we need those strict
conditions and until now it's not
something that telekinesis has been able
to live up to period if you want to
learn more about the scientific method
and why certain types of claims require
specific types of scientific evidence
click the link under this video and
check out the great new course offered
by the University of Edinburgh called
introduction to the philosophy of
physical sciences it's one of thousands
of courses you'll find at class -
central.com / Pakman whether it's
political science psychology sociology
physics business comps I almost anything
you can imagine they have courses from
MIT Stanford Berkeley and tons of the
courses are totally free get started
watching College lectures on topics you
love right now by clicking the link
underneath this video